you have these these doctors in the
family and this way I bring it up my
dad's a doctor and when I was a kid what
kind of doctor microbiologist any time I
would ask my dad or I'd say I was sick
or I don't feel well he'd be like yeah
you'll be fine get to school
that's a doctor's approach have you
found that to be true like your sister
who's a doctor if you start to complain
to them about something they're often
dismissive right no so I I went and I
went to Morocco mm-hmm I came home
things were not right mm-hmm
that's a nice way to say it yeah yeah
because no one wants to get in you
always be like man did I have diarrhea
but you have a spokesman for diarrhea
yeah I got bills to pay but Andy will
have photos and everything you just said
things we're not right right well things
were not right it's hard to distinguish
between just a normal Jewish stomach and
some serious gone down yeah yeah
yeah literally yeah yeah so I went I try
not to call my sister ever because she
just thinks I'm annoying and a
hypochondriac and so I went to the
hospital for tropical diseases in London
and I got my sample of my situation
turned in and the lovely man was like I
think it sounds like you had jart you
have Giardia so I'm gonna give you
antibiotics but are you Giardia
okay I know what that is yeah no it's
like a bacterial yeah it's like a
microbe in you know pond water right
my dad would know what that was if we
spoke come on
[Applause]
so anyway myself up here I love my dad I
just love to give him a on TV so um
they're minimal interventionists you
know they don't like to give a lot of
medicine and the big their big point is
you always go to the doctor right when
you're the most sick cuz you're the most
uncomfortable and then you usually get
medication but and then you attribute it
to having gotten the medication when
really it's just regression to the mean
keep up with me Harvard let's go you
lost me it's nice to see you Conan no
you go back to what happens is eat your
your sickest and then you go to the
doctor but you would have gotten better
anyway you've not gone to the temporal
confounding variable so they were
blabbing on and on about how I probably
didn't really have Giardia and Blasi
blue even though when I took the
antibiotics I felt better and my
situation was normal sure gotcha several
did you say temporal what did you say
temporal what a confounding variable you
were out here five minutes ago saying
you can't work a cheese grater I don't
know what is it
[Applause]
I'm not buying this not buying it
[Music]
you're a liar you're a lie we have a
clip here from Brock Meyer I want to
make sure we get to wait I just have to
tell you the end of the bloody story I
got a big laugh we're done all right
tell you the doctor the hospital called
me and they said and my sister was like
sure yes it could because of the
antibiotics and I was like it was from
the antibiotic that's why I'm better and
then of course the guy called and said
you don't have Giardia right and I
couldn't tell her because she was right
competitive right I'm so angry you
weren't mad that you weren't desperately
sick yeah weirdest thing I've heard in a
long time
damn my sister I'm not really sick why I
took the medication for no reason
uprightly right and it was infuriating
never never go to the doctor is there
message here
if you're not feeling well I hope you're
watching kids just don't go it'll clear
up on its own
[Applause]
take it from a man - Pete no matter how
bad it gets don't consult the doctor and
hear the end of it from my family
you